[Music]
they by your side does it change the way
that you present yourself or yeah
there's fish okay he gave me the rest of
him not stronger I feel stronger I feel
stronger I step forward I say what I
mean I mean what I say I stand up for my
kids and I feel like I'm the leader of
my family and my my oldest 16 is not the
man of the house that you have to have
your own dreams
and the twins they didn't suffer because
I told them the truth we've got a
beautiful new I haven't heard it yet but
I'm assuming it's beautiful original new
song Beauty and the Beast soundtrack
coming out I'm very touched I have to
tell you that it's been 30 years later
they're coming back to me I see the
movie it's great but there's something
that's inside of me that's shaking a
little bit and I cannot and they say so
what do you think
would you consider singing the new
beauty and this reading to be sung 30
years later if you be honest with you I
said to them that it's so hard for me to
commit right now because I was feeling
like cheating with the first Beauty in
the video I understood that it was an
amazing privilege again Beauty and the
Beast had brought me to where I am today
what a privilege once again absolutely I
gotta talk to Rene and he said you
should
and what about your reaction to John
Legend ariana grande doing a new version
of your iconic song hey I can't refuse
that it's pretty normal so proud I'm so
proud
I mean if you get to get older that's
the way things should be men
you